le sujet est fort intéressant maintenant
certains ils sont plus sensibles que
d'autres
mais les chiffres que vous allez voir ne
mentent pas montréal serait une ville
bruyante et pas à cause de tous les
festivals et concerts ça c'est bien on
est content mais pour d'autres raisons
anne louise despatie on comprend qu'on
peut comprendre une ville puis la
rebâtir tout d'un coup mais quand on
reconstruit il y a des façons de
prévenir la pollution sonore
produite par les moyens de transport les
automobiles mais aussi les trains et les
avions
moi je demeure à belmont royal et jo
c'est un gros problème parce que nos
maisons ne sont pas isolés alors on
entend les avions tout le temps la
direction de la santé publique de
montréal a mesuré le bruit sur 87 sites
à l'été 2010 les résultats de ces
mesures sur 24 heures montre que les
deux tiers des sites dépasse le seuil de
55 décibels que recommande
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
ministère des transports du québec fiq
son seuil à 65 décibels et si ça se
produit régulièrement
une période répéter les bruits sont
intenses on peut aussi avoir des
problèmes cardiovasculaires notamment de
l'hypertension williams dizaine de cours
de triage ferroviaire dans l'est de
montréal est un aéroport international a
ajouté au bruit du transport routier la
santé publique considère que c'est un
problème mais comparable à d'autres
grandes villes comme toronto
la direction de la santé publique et la
vient de montréal propose donc que tous
les joueurs concernés conviennent d'une
politique régionale sur le bruit lié au
transport une concertation qui pourrait
déboucher sur des mesures concrètes
entre autres pour les promoteurs
immobiliers à la hauteur de scénarios
possibles on peut être dans une
situation où on va dire aux promoteurs
vous allez mettre un double vitrage on
peut être dans une situation où on va
dire aux promoteurs les chambres à
l'arrière les chambres vont être à
l'arrière
ce ne sont que des recommandations des
souhaits pour l'instant mais qui devront
tenir compte de bien des choses
par exemple si on interdit le camionnage
de nuit comme c'est le cas sur notre
dame dans la ronde
ce mot merci hochelaga maisonneuve il
faudra aussi que la police soit là pour
faire respecter le règlement
ici anne louise despatie radio-canada
mourir